josé espinosa il est militant chez les
jeunes
bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur arte france alors un appel à la
mobilisation au travers toute la france
que doit-on en attendre beaucoup de
monde aujourd'hui je crois qu'il y aura
beaucoup de monde et qui manifestera
malgré le mauvais temps
voyons évidemment les entrées oui je
voulais dire simplement rappelé que
l'utilisation des drones a été déjà fait
lors des manifestations des gilet jaune
et nous avions protesté énergiquement
contre cette mesure et je vois que le
gouvernement non seulement continuer à
l'appliquer bien en plus ils s'évertuent
à la ligier de telle manière que ça
devienne dans le droit commun alors que
l'onu et d'autres organismes
internationaux y compris européens comme
dans de la france sur ses utilisations à
lui alors à 20 seulement contre la loi
sécurité globale mais aussi pour
dénoncer les violences policières la
surveillance de masse et il est jaune
ont beaucoup appellent à une convergence
des luttes
est ce que c'est ce qu'on est en train
de vivre en ce moment je ne sais pas si
on peut parler de convergence de lutte
moi je serais plus j'ai toujours été
pour l'idée que ses pairs simplement des
convergences de lutte qui se développe
mais eux c'est une association de lutte
diversifié qui forment ce front large
contre la politique du gouvernement
voyez c'est pas c'est pas simplement un
élément de de cohérence mais c'est aussi
un élément d'élargissement de l'ensemble
des forces qui luttent contre cette
politique qui est néfaste dans tous ses
aspects à la fois répressif mais aussi
sur des questions sociales sur des
questions économiques sur des questions
sanitaires aujourd'hui autre récent
rassemblement déjà prévu le
janvier prochain à ce que vous espérez
du changement des décisions qui vont
être prises d'ici à la fin du mois
malheureusement j'ai je pense que le
gouvernement n'est pas propice à reclus
et disons qu'il veut nous imposer une
politique répressive
c'est voyez s'il ya des lois sécurité
globale mais depuis il ya eu plusieurs
décret qui sont sortis pour briser
encore le comment dire lui mettre désir
de liberté ils veulent eux ils veulent
vraiment à mourir notre manière d'être
notre manière d'intervenir
voilà assez c'est toutes les mesures qui
sont prises soient elles vous fichez le
dernier décret c'est quand ils veulent
nous ficher en raison de nos opinions
politiques religieuses dans notre train
de vie notre façon de voir les choses
c'est un petit peu le ce que dénonce et
1984 vous savez le le livre d'ordre a
pris oui jésus nous inventions ont plus
de possibilités qui est liberticide et
qui vraiment vers l'encontre de ce qu'il
faut bien aujourd'hui parce
qu'aujourd'hui on a besoin de beaucoup
de démocraties on a besoin de beaucoup
de participation pour justement avoir un
bon sentiment à ce qui se passe sur le
pont vers ce pays
josé spinoza merci d'avoir été en direct
avec nous d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
militant
j'ai des jaunes merci à vous merci au
revoir